such a game that mdf
now i had a couple of
times he now played
pushing against springer f3 he
probably does that now too
can you play something that
i agree with
somehow something like that
well
that should be good now
i have it  my doubts somehow
but ok i didn't want
to exceed the time directly now of
course a strange position well
probably i didn't play that well either
but
yes
feeds
46 that's all shaky of course
you would like to have the pawn back on
kids
so
maybe you're surprised  the chance
if he gives me the chance to
play doesn't take away at all
maybe the weird breeding to me 3
that makes the follower 5 each
but then somehow g7 and c7
looks so strange again but
I would have only
considered
killing it well sprinkle it in
so that's also forced if
i go now they take tours
g8
is more than strange
i  could also take here of course
well at least he can no longer so
easily long break here i assume
runner maybe also that very easy
g7 g8 g5
canada not at all next to the pawn
countries with the
lady i have runners for six years
interesting except that i times
I'm about to exceed the time again
, oh
god,
the order has now simply been
won for white, I think that's
a quality for now,
the h3 tower as an idea to
activate it
so you actually had to do that and
manage 20 seconds
aha7 missed
yes i put myself in
trouble again but of
course for total merck for the
position is increasing